see web joining us now did you ever try
to do stand-up comedy Chris he said all
the college football
no oh come on like to be the first of
all to be a comedian you gotta kind of
have had some problems and are willing
to share them with the world and they're
the most like vulnerable people and I
think that you know for them to get on
stage or I have a couple of friends that
are actually like stand-up guys that you
know they have that struggling actors
mentality where they don't get much and
they're on the wrong for years but I
know a lot more like I guess it's all
perspective because I know a lot of
stories of athletes make it so I see
less success and athlete that I do and
be an other thing
who's the funniest guy you've ever been
around a teammate or player player you
played against like who would be a
stand-up comedian there's a lot of guys
are funny violent they can handle the
crowd but I'd say party of course he's
he's mr. Vaughn lino he's funny all the
time not saying J will man Jason wins he
literally probably the funniest guy I've
ever been around my whole ivc's and
appropriately funny he's appropriately
funny funny at the wrong time funny when
you should be sad he's funny must be hot
though that's just who he is no Jay will
definitely try the funniest cut out of
that before I get to a game for tonight
with the Warriors and the Rockets Reggie
Miller was on yesterday he talked about
first time he played against LeBron
LeBron mister rookie do you remember the
first time you played against LeBron I
do remember that um I got a chance to go
home in Detroit and in place of the
pictures it was always extreme and we
were you know there six Eastern
Conference Finals my first Eastern
Conference final championship up with
the game in Detroit and LeBron I think
it was 25 of the four quarters Oh so I
played against I think and I was talking
to so much I think I actually was
talking to
we were talking about they did American
in saying that we think that game is
what built the LeBron Francis I mean of
course every game he played but when he
had that game against the defense of the
Pistons came back and won on the road
and then went on to the championship to
me I didn't play against the first Lavar
but I played against one of the best of
them and I saw how great he was early
but what's that feeling like when
somebody's putting up 25 and a quarter
you know it happened about AI was so
tough to stop and but I only had that
feeling with Michael Jordan who I was
thinking I like 52 or 54 56 on us when I
was in Washington in the playoffs I'm
gonna think in the middle of the game
Jordan sold his soul to the devil
harmless I remember I told your honor I
would like he sold his soul to the devil
doing this go away
he's supposed to make that shot right
and we just had to take it a laughable
abroad it was so different because he
was soon in hitting threes he would
double team and he was coming down the
lane dunking and we got a big physical
team I mean why was Michael Wallace you
know all these guys Dale Davis big big
guys and he was just he was he was he
was a man child and that's what he
wanted hit you just he can really see
the floor you age and past he can do all
the great thing is he's so skilled but
he's so strong as well and I know we
give him credit for that now but I just
remember thinking I can't believe how
young this kid is and how strong is he
could be playing football I thought we
would take it what did you see last
night well clearly yeah more Boston you
know that series is no weird
this is so weird what I saw that night
is at home a lot of players have
confidence and it's really good you know
Kyle Korver playing when I saw that
fighters even though they traded for all
these other guys it's about the guys
that's in there the kind of player
campuses the guys are stepping up with
heart but I just don't know if it'll
travel I didn't I didn't know if it was
gonna I didn't know if they were gonna
play that hard last night and I think
comes down to playing hard and I think
people just credit how important the
crowd is like crowds are so important
and when you have a crowd that
constantly keeps them pumped up I mean
you're gonna play hard and I just
can they take that on the road when
they're getting boobs can they turn
those boozing for that same type of
image we're talking to Chris Webber he's
got the call tonight with Marv Albert
and Reggie Miller 9:00 Eastern on TNT
Game four rockets and the Warriors how
important is this game tonight we
usually look at pivotal Game five but
man there's a whole lot riding on this
game tonight Chris the fun thing about
working with Reggie is that most of time
we agree and when we don't we just go at
each other and with this series we've
agreed on almost everything that we
thought the last game was the biggest of
the series for Houston you just don't
want to get down to go understand and
we're all talking about how well step
current play all right and stuff Corey
play great Thompson didn't play that
great thanks Pierre what up boom yeah so
I almost think that we're almost making
it easier that's a great name but they
were already destroying them and so to
me when you have a clone with the
mentality of growing space tonight their
mentality is going to be just put your
foot on their neck don't let them
breathe and that's why I stand I think
it's going to just have to be you know
all hands on deck and I think Chris Paul
is gonna have to play great like he has
all series but he's gonna have to have a
pink impact tonight because if they lose
this game because loudest this I mean is
going to be this series the series is
over more unguardable James Harden or
Kevin Durant James Harden
I think I'm in Iran they're both great
scorers but I think James Harden only
because we're not only because of his
boron like he's a one-man fast break man
he's Euro step you know he led the
league I'm asking I'm free-throw to
getting to the line you know the way
that he handles the ball you know he can
go right or left in time and then his
shooting and we the people and harden
has to be you know light up there on
that first tier not to be stuffed with
light on that first year I couldn't
check either one of them but Durant is
so beautiful because he's taller than 70
and his game is like watching you know
ballerina
so they both so hard to score but I
would you said because Arden has the
ball in his hands against the dribble
450 times again you know
that's that's pretty incredible and uh
you know I think he's showcased a little
bit more of a bull I'm so tough to stop
when I watched her rant with his shot as
jumper starts on the left side of his
head and then comes back over to the
right side so it's it's a slight
movement adjustment there it's not a
normal one and then I look at Lanza wall
which is more of a almost a windshield
wiper there Jude is there any way you
think you could shorten up Lonzo ball
shot where it could maybe be where
Durant where Durant starts I'm not gonna
say it's gonna look like that but
dérailleur does start on the left side
him and moves over with his jumper well
you know I'm a great golfer and TV guys
over there just shout out to their
freaking beat but you know a golf swing
everybody has different golf swing we've
got a guy like Furyk you know and to me
I played with the guy you remember Kevin
Martin he played for Sacramento and went
to Minnesota yeah he averaged winning
yeah I was 20 many years you know and so
one day I was with coach career was
working him out as a rookie and everyone
was saying to him changed your jump shot
to me it's the same exact shot his balls
is really ugly it comes low to high and
he was saying well unless you talk about
the jumps I have an advantage a knock
down the shot that you'll have a
quickest pump fake because it takes so
long and lined up you just have to act
like you want enough if you mean yeah I
know
ball has a shot the ball well I know you
haven't shot the ball well but if he
shoots the ball well that shot it's okay
I mean everybody shot is different and
it's really no correct way to shoot it
unless it goes in and you lean it was
more about someone you know it was more
about the defense in the league took his
confidence it was more about you know
you claim your first minute Patrick bag
but probably you know just want to be
around here and I just think that he
just needs to make that shot better I'm
not one of the people I says need to
change a shot reg might say that and
listen the range over me you're not in
that area but I think that his jump shot
is in saleable I don't think he should
change it and I just think you need more
consistency and understand that the
defense in the league is a little bit
different and how do you mitigate that
speed with his downside but I don't
think it's a going away and start all
over because I thought that's pretty
tough to do did you hear
I I asked reg a challenge I said if I
blindfolded him could he make more
threes than Ben Simmons he said yes he
would he'd make more threes than Simmons
blindfolded this movie this Duncan's
room you have to have prosthetic this is
a terrible process great movie but take
three hours to make where we were
playing basketball so we're hurting we
only have a couple of days to be able to
give you some of our body and we're
hurting and it's like the third day we
can't even walk and I just started
talking junk to read to entertain us and
no he would go out on the court and he
walked on the coordinates all prosthetic
stuff and I was saying spike these
behind this man and he just knocked out
seven threes outside like it was nothing
his jump shot still is pure and I have
some was the last time he shot he was
like maybe a year and a half ago wedges
jump shot is is pure now his jump shot
wasn't the pretty known until it went
but every time you saw that that kind of
right hand go to the left and it was
kind of a weird of the leg motion we
actually had a real jump shot but man it
was a set yep he can still he could
still give somebody five or ten minutes
he could be a Kyle Korver I think for
somebody in the in the fall yeah yeah I
know these are holding up he can run off
those screens he can he can knock it
down all he needs a little bit of space
and you know he still got that kickstand
so he's not getting a couple em once but
you're coming out there Tripathi while
he knocks down the three so where's
always knows how to put a missile
Doggett Chris good to talk to you have
fun tonight
always a pleasure thanks for joining us
have to rethink my thing now about
basketball though because I don't know
I've kind of agree with you guys about
sports but anyway thank you guys thank
you Chris for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]